il ya 50 ans cette année un grand parti
voyait le jour ce parti notre parti
votre parti le parti québécois a donné
énormément au québec
et franchement il veut continuer et en
donner encore plus
nous avons eu cinq fois le privilège de
former le gouvernement du québec et de
la loi 101 à la sortie du nucléaire
nous avons su bien utiliser ce privilège
pour tous les gens de ce pays
nous assumons le choc ce soir mais nous
nous tenons droit et fort parce que le
québec a encore besoin du parti
québécois
défaite amère du parti québécois hier 17
% des voix 9 députés seulement et dont
j'en parle avec nous ils vous donner
notre collaboratrice régulière une
émission chroniqueur au quotidien le
devoir mais qui a été qui a assisté à la
naissance de ce parti lors de ses
premières années
1 deux ans plus tard adam tir de 70
jusqu'en 2012 alors vous avez été une
militante fervente souverainisme n'est
plus membre de ce parti québécois là on
va peut-être vous avez quitté le parti
notamment lorsque le malt et madame
marois ont voulu faire passer cette loi
pour créer l'instar d'autres ont à
québec
ça sent vraiment sûrs mais jésus celle
des dépenses reste est plus important
qu'on dit oui c'était plus important
parce qu'il y avait derrière choix autre
chose un façon justement d'être partie
du coin entre un grand bout de chemin
monsieur disait comment réagissez vous à
ce qu'il a dit hier soir vous écoutez
moi je pense que le problème du parti
québécois il est plus profond que tout
ce que c'est sûr j'écoutais sylvain
gaudreault hottentot ah bon la jeune
gabrielle lemieux est une toute jeune
femme qui est présidente du parti qui
est formidable et jean françois lisée
aussi c'est dur à reconnaître une chose
à mon aise
et c'est que le parti québécois a été
créé pour faire l'indépendance du québec
il a essayé deux fois il a échoué deux
fois certains vous diront que la
dernière fois meilleur ça a été plus ou
moins en être que cette campagne
référendaire du côté du nom surtout du
côté d'ottawa
mais la réalité c'est celle là et est
donc un parti qui a été créé pour faire
l'indépendance puis qui n'est pas
capable de la faire ça devient un moment
donné lourd à porter je crois et sajoo
sens je pense
structurellement sur le parti québécois
actuel quant à la conjoncture
jean-françois disait fait un pari qui
était celui de dire on reporte justement
donc un référendum il y en aurait pas
dans un premier mandat
on va présenter un programme
progressiste dont les québécois semblait
vouloir d'après les différents sondages
c'est à dire pas de baisses d'impôts
mais des réinvestissements en éducation
en santé en environnement achètera donc
un programme qui pouvaient intéressant
et il s'est dit ils sont dits dans leur
tête que avec ce programme là
l'alternative le changement ce serait
eux et non pas la cac
c'est ça qui échoue et en même temps on
se rappelle au début les batailles du pq
pour le bon gouvernement
1les le déficit zéro par la suite ça a
été une longue trajectoire parce que
gouverner et défendre une cause ça a été
un peu difficile peu particulier pour ça
que c'est facile il ya deux parties là
qu'ils ont été en montée hier les deux
particules jamais gouverné québec
solidaire donc son la gauche
sinon extrêmement tout cas vraiment a
trait à ganges et puis la carte
alors c'est sûr que ça peut être tentant
dont on parle de changement de dire on
va aller du compte et non pas des partis
qui ont été justement des partis au
gouvernement on voit ce qu'il a fait il
pasqua écouté a honnêtement c'est comme
impossible à dire parce que il faut
quand même remarquer depuis 2003 là il
ya eu une lente 10
du parti québécois avec un petit sursaut
en 2012 qu'un gouvernement minoritaire
mais qu'est-ce que ça prendrait en
d'autres termes pour stopper cette lente
descente et ce déclin constant eh ben
c'est pas elle cherche seulement là
parce que honnêtement il n'a eu beaucoup
de chefs de toutes sortes de pierre
carles qui était dans un genre et plus
de pauline dans un autre genre
jean-françois dans un troisième genre
par dreamworks l'air dans un quatrième
gens et c'est pour ça que je dis stone
la de ce commun comment renaître je
dirais spectaculaire non pour 2022 moi
je j'ai évidemment pas la réponse mais
je pense que c'était une vraie question
qu'est ce que le particulier quoi doit
faire se réinventer se transforme et
devenir un nouveau parti ce que c'est la
marque aussi parti québécois qui traîne
depuis 50 ans en corée semble qu'une
fusion ne soit absolument pas possible
le sujet mais cela ne tienne on savait
que le mode de scrutin qui va faire
qu'on va le prendre place et encore il
peut y avoir il y aurait pu y avoir
malgré tout prix pourrait éventuellement
y avoir un impact quelconque de non
agression des plages a pas présenté à
quand vous avez d'être commercial contre
les chefs de partis ça aurait été la
moindre des choses puisque justement des
cuves et lui présenter personnes qui ont
une réelle nadeau dubois
alors il peut on peut imaginer quand
même si quelques chacun veut rester dans
son coin mais moi mon avis si chacun
reste dans son coin parti québécois va
falloir qu'il devienne autre chose
là il s'est campé à gauche c'est vrai
avec pierre carli était campé à droite
avec pauline au centre et c'est
difficile à suivre pour les pour les
citoyens et les électeurs alors qu'est
ce que ce serait un new york
comme sous tony blair moi je sais bien
qu alexandre cloutier en tout cas à
l'époque il y pensait achats il aurait
atterri chez assa quelques pas de son
dernier mot alors je pense que je joue
moins je recommanderais pas de revenir
maman louise beaudoin et merci on
poursuit la conversation diffusée dans
le carnet politique avec françois
cardinal mais c'est quand même un moment
historique
oui